let me thank you very much let's get to
the flooding in Michigan because the
city in Central Michigan faces what
officials call a 500 year flood disaster
and the governor is now calling for
federal aid the rush of water spilling
through two failed dams and houses
houses floating away the water is
several feet deep in much of Midland
that is northwest of Saginaw Michigan
and it's another severe blow for a state
that's reported more than 53,000
coronavirus cases Janet shamlian is in
Midland talking with people whose lives
have been upended by this flooding and
Janet good morning before we get to
those interviews how are conditions
where you are right now well Toni good
morning to you let me just say that the
river crested at just above 35 feet and
as you can see behind me this bridge is
impassable and so our roads all over
town this morning could it have been
prevented that's a question many in the
community are asking right now there's a
lot of frustration here I'm in to
reports that those dams both of them
violated federal safety regulations a
home floating downstream ripped from its
foundation by raging floodwaters one
example of the devastation in Central
Michigan this morning there's concern
flood waters may be mixing with toxins
and containment ponds from a nearby Dow
Chemical Plant which shut down its
operations the company says there's no
risk to people or the environment due to
the amount of water across the county it
will take multiple days to recede close
to 10,000 evacuated Midland County as
the floodwaters came gushing in power is
out in many areas and it's still too
early for some to go home I don't know
what's gonna happen Thomas Courtney
Kessler hope she'll be able to get back
into her house today
a neighbor sent her these photos of
water swampy the basement with water to
the ceiling she's not the only one
memories as a family are in her basement
and they're floating they're ruined
Kerry Ellen told us the flooding will
cost her family tens of thousands of
dollars and she's frustrated the
breached Edenvale and Sanford dams
weren't in better condition both are
owned by Boise hydro which had its
license at the nearly said
three old Eatonville facility revoked by
federal authorities in 2018 after more
than a decade of safety violations
raised questions about its ability to
withstand a major flood like this one
yet when the dam came under state
supervision it was deemed to be in fair
condition this could have been prevented
and it wasn't it's all happening during
a pandemic yeah
that's made it extra interesting in the
middle of covin you start to realize
what's important and I think without
that maybe it would have been a little
harder there's no doubt coronaviruses on
the minds of many people here even as
they deal with this flooding and as we
head into a holiday weekend it won't
feel like it for a lot of people here
Tony they will finally be able to get
back in their homes and start the
cleanup process it's a difficult process
indeed Jay